The first thing to take a look at will be rebuilding one of our IK arms using a more
tailored function, so the IK 2 bone function.
Now just by design, this IK 2 bone function is a simpler setup than the basic IK solver
we were using previously, so we won't need as many nodes in the rig graph and that will
enable us to work a bit more efficiently.
It's also specifically designed and can only be used for three joint chains, like arms
and legs, where you have the end of the chain or your effector, like your hand or your foot,
and then like a lower limb and an upper limb, where you only really need to worry about
controlling the end of the chain and then bending the chain at one point towards the
pole vector control like the elbow or the knee.
So inside the engine here, if I right click inside our rig graph and search for IK 2 bone,
this is our IK 2 bone function.
Now we can go over here and break down what information the function needs to work properly.
So similar to the basic IK solver, we're going to need a primary and a secondary axis,
which would be our axis pointing down the bone, the primary axis, and the secondary axis
is our up axis.
We also then need our pole vector control and our end control, so the end control will
be either your hand or your foot in this example, and then it also needs to know the three bones
in the chain that you need to be controlling.
So it's actually a very straightforward setup once you have your two controls created.
Now let's replace the logic for our left IK arm and use this function instead.
So I'm going to start off by removing the existing IK logic for our left arm.
So let's just bring this over here a little bit, and I'm going to alt click to disconnect
the basic IK and just drag that over here because we're not going to need it anymore,
and bring in our IK 2 bone function.
And we're going to start to input the information for our function here.
Now looking at the primary and secondary axes, we know from our previous basic IK setup that
the primary x axis is 1 and our secondary axis is y minus 1.
And just to double check that, we can see primary axis and secondary axis.
Now as a reminder, if you want to check on your own skeleton, if you come up to the option
box here and make sure display axes on selection is ticked, that way whenever you select one
of these bones here, you'll be able to see the orientation axis.
Now all we need to do is input the control information and the bone information.
So for our control, we have the pole vector node first.
Now you can use the drop down here that will just search for whatever type you have set here,
so it will search for controls.
And we want our pole vector L control.
Or you could come into the rig graph here and we need to find our end control, so that's
going to be our hand control.
And from the hierarchy, select it and hit this little arrow to input the information there.
Finally our bone change just needs adding.
So we're going to start with bone A from the furthest bone from our end control.
And that's going to be our upper arm.
And then bone B will be our lower arm and bone C will be our hand.
So if I search in here for upper arm, make sure we grab the left side here.
Bone B is going to be our lower arm and again make sure you grab the left side.
And bone C is going to be our hand L.
And really that's all this node needs, that's all the information it needs to be set up correctly.
So if I connect up the logic between our basic IK and our AIM node, just hit compile.
We should see, there we go, that our IK2 bone function is set up and working as expected.
And it really is that simple to set up once you have your controls set up and once you
know your primary and secondary axis.
And if I open up the function here, just by double clicking.
And if I double click to open up the function here, you'll see that it's comprised of a
whole network of nodes here doing all the logic and all the calculations behind the
scenes.
And when it's all wrapped up into a container like this, you don't have all of these nodes
and all of this spaghetti visible in the main grid graph.
And you can see how it really helped to clean up and simplify the setup of your control rig.
So as you can see, functions can be extremely powerful and really speed up a lot of your
rigging workflow.
And something great about them is that they work kind of like a blueprint.
So you could create a library of custom functions like this.
And as long as you make them public, you can use them across all of the control rigs within
your project.
And we're going to take a look at how to create one of these next.